(upbeat vocal percussion music)
(logo sparkling)
♪ Whoa, oh, whoa oh ♪
♪ I'm a superstar ♪
♪ Now that everybody's waiting for me ♪
♪ It's not too hard ♪
(stars sparkling)
- Hey, what up, y'all?
Welcome back to HCL.
We are in Hollywood.
I've got the answers, and
the answers this morning
is Mother Majesty.
Thank you for being here, Mother Majesty.
- Thank you for having me! (laughs)
(crowd cheering)
- Yeah.
Now, before the break, we heard your song
"Shenomenon" from the new
hit album "Girl Army."
- Oh, yep.
(crowd cheering)
- Yeah.
- That's right.
Well, thank you so much, Scratch.
You know, this whole album is about girls
and empowering girls, and you know,
kinda just showing girls
that they can be strong
and powerful and do what they wanna do
and not what the media
says they need to do.
- All right, all right, that's deep.
(crowd cheering)
That's deep.
Now, we got some young females here
who have some questions for you.
Is that okay?
- Oh, it's always okay. It's always okay.
I always wanna hear from my Girl Army.
- Hi, Majesty, it is so cool to meet you.
- Thank you so much.
I think you're beautiful just like that.
- Um, yeah, so okay.
Last week, I took your advice
from your song "Get Some,"
and I flaunted it till he wanted it.
But I ended up losing my virginity
to a guy that I don't know.
- You see, it is time for girls
to take back their power nowadays
'cause it's your body, and it's your mind,
and you should use that to
feel sexy and empowered.
(crowd cheering)
- [Fan] Okay.
Okay, yeah, yeah, but now I'm pregnant.
- Miracles. Next question.
(crowd cheering)
- Hi, hi, Majesty.
I'm Cassie. I think your album rocks.
- Thank you so much, Cassie.
I think you should never change your skin.
- Okay, so in your song
"Friday Night Freakdown"--
- Thank you so much, Cassie.
- You say, "Bend it
over, touch the ground.
He'll ride you like his merry-go-round."
- Yes, I do.
- Is that about butt sex?
- What it's about, Cassie,
is us reclaiming our bodies as women,
because you know, for a long time,
being sexy was about being sexy for a man,
but this is about being sexy for yourself.
- [Crowd Member] Woo!
- But I've got herpes in my butt.
- Okay, let's change tracks for a second.
We gonna go to commercial.
When we come back,
Mother Majesty is going
to unfurl her new song.
What is it about?
- Oh, okay, it's kind of a love song.
And it's about finding strength
after having your heart broken.
- All right, we gonna go to commercial.
When we come back, Mother Majesty with,
"Who Got Next on This Blackberry Pie?"
(crowd cheering)
- Here's your dressing room, Your Majesty.
- Thank you so much.
- [Staff Member] Yep.
(Mother Majesty sighs)
(eerie ambient music)
- That's right, girls.
Being overly sexual and being
strong are the same thing.
It's the same thing.
(chuckles) It's the same thing.
(Mother Majesty laughing maniacally)
Girl power! (laughs)
(coughs) God.
I'm allergic to this makeup. (sniffs)
(Mother Majesty coughs)
(Mother Majesty burps)
Now why would I have burped?
That's weird.
(crowd cheering)
(smooth R&B music)
(men vocalizing softly)
♪ You know that I've been waiting ♪
♪ Had this feeling for so long ♪
♪ And it feels so right baby ♪
♪ How could this feeling be wrong ♪
♪ Sometimes the thing that
you've been searching for ♪
♪ Has been right there the whole time ♪
♪ So baby, I'm here here to tell you ♪
♪ I'm waiting right here
just to make you all mine ♪
♪ You, you're the one I always hoped for ♪
♪ You, it's a feeling I can't hide ♪
♪ You, and I always been here, baby ♪
♪ Standing right here by your side ♪
♪ Yeah, it's been
building up inside of me ♪
♪ And I just gotta come out ♪
♪ And tell you what I'm feeling, girl ♪
♪ Tellin' you I love you's
what I'm talking about ♪
♪ Mm, gotta tell you what my heart knows ♪
♪ And what it has known for so long ♪
♪ I finally need to show you ♪
♪ My arms are wide open,
that's where you belong ♪
♪ You, you know I'm making
love to you gently ♪
♪ You, the way I've seen it in my mind ♪
♪ You, I will take care of you, baby ♪
♪ The ain't no rush, baby,
let's take our sweet time ♪
♪ I'll do it to you slow, the
way you never done before ♪
♪ Well, open up your mind,
I will open up your door ♪
♪ I've been searching all around
for the one I can call mine ♪
♪ Sometimes the thing
you're searching for ♪
♪ Has been there the whole time ♪
♪ You, I wanna give you all I got now ♪
♪ You, and I'll take all you can give ♪
♪ You, and I'll never
turn my back on you ♪
♪ As long as we both shall live ♪
♪ I'm talking about you ♪
♪ You, standing right in front of you ♪
♪ You, woo, nothing left to hide ♪
♪ You, sugar, said I'm
tellin' you everything ♪
♪ I've kept buried deep inside ♪
♪ I'm rubbing up against ♪
♪ Your big bald head ♪
♪ I said your big bald
head now, now, now ♪
♪ There's no one else I could
be possibly talkin' about ♪
♪ 'Cause you are bald, and you are here ♪
(smooth R&B music)
♪ You, you're a woman, I'm a man now ♪
♪ You, and you know that's how I like it ♪
♪ You, and I'm specifically
talking about ♪
♪ You, because you're a
girl and I am the opposite ♪
♪ You, woman, woman, woman, woman, woman ♪
♪ You, you are a woman, I am a man ♪
♪ You, you know I like women ♪
♪ You, because I am a man ♪
♪ You, never liked a
man in my life before ♪
♪ You, and I don't like one now ♪
(intense electronic music)
♪ Baby, baby ♪
♪ It looks like we're back together ♪
♪ And it's like nothing had ever ♪
♪ Torn us apart ♪
♪ Honey, honey ♪
♪ We'll let bygones be bygones ♪
♪ Gonna get a second try-on ♪
♪ Gonna have a fresh start ♪
♪ So tonight I'm gonna hit that ♪
♪ Tonight I'm gonna hit that, hit that ♪
♪ Tonight I'm gonna hit
that, hit that, hit that ♪
♪ And don't try to fight back ♪
♪ Your feelings ♪
♪ Sugar, sugar ♪
♪ Just get into my car ♪
♪ And I'll take you so far ♪
♪ From where anyone can see ♪
♪ Lover, lover ♪
♪ Let's just walk and take it slow ♪
♪ In crowded places so they'll know ♪
♪ That you're back with me ♪
♪ So tonight I'm gonna hit that ♪
♪ Tonight I'm gonna hit that, hit that ♪
♪ Tonight I'm gonna hit that ♪
(taser clattering)
(Chris Brown screaming)
- I'm sorry.
It was an involuntary reaction.
(taser clattering)
(door handle banging)
(high-heels clicking)
(car door banging)
- Who you gonna call?
(Ray Parker Jr. laughs)
Hi, I'm Ray Parker Jr.,
writer and performer
of the Academy Award-nominated
hit single "Ghostbusters,"
from the major motion
picture "Ghostbusters."
But that's just one song.
I've written so many other
major motion picture theme songs
and submitted them throughout the years.
Now they're available and together
for one specially-priced compilation.
Songs like...
♪ You tried to play the game ♪
♪ But it's driving you insane ♪
♪ "Jumanji," danger in the jungle ♪
♪ "Jumanji," there's a lion in my house ♪
♪ Come on, Mr. Computer ♪
♪ Throw me a bone, I said ♪
♪ "Lawnmower Man" ♪
♪ Get up off of my lawn ♪
♪ When "Armageddon" is near ♪
♪ You better get outta here ♪
♪ Looking like a "Deep Impact" ♪
♪ I ain't afraid of no 'stroid ♪
♪ Watch out behind you,
they're trying to find you ♪
♪ "Pelican Brief" ♪
♪ It's gettin' legal, y'all ♪
These songs have only been heard
by the highest level of
industry decision-makers.
But now you can feel like
a Hollywood executive
in your own home.
♪ I see your "Face/Off" ♪
♪ Bad guy walking around ♪
♪ It's a "Face/Off" ♪
♪ (laughs) That ain't even your face ♪
♪ "Passion of the Christ" ♪
♪ Get me down off of this cross ♪
♪ You know my daddy is the boss ♪
♪ "Disturbia" ♪
♪ That's not even a word ♪
♪ Gonna unnerve ya ♪
♪ Now there's a whole lotta kinky ♪
♪ Bet that room is stinky ♪
♪ "Fifty Shades of Grey" ♪
♪ (laughs) All right, white people ♪
♪ Who's a slave ♪
♪ I'm not a slave, uh-oh ♪
♪ "12 Years a Slave" ♪
♪ Whoops (imitates whip cracking) ♪
(ice jingles)
There's one thing I know,
is that persistence makes perfection.
(laughs) Sure, Hollywood missed out.
But that doesn't mean you have to.
♪ Down in the basement ♪
♪ What's going on ♪
♪ It's a "Apt Pupil" ♪
♪ There's a kid and a Nazi down there ♪
(upbeat funk music)
- [Announcer] Order now to
receive your free copy of
"Bobby Sings the Twos,"
theme songs to sequels
that were never made.
(cash register rings)
(grandiose progressive metal music)
♪ There's a light ♪
♪ And it shines within the
darkness of the sands of time ♪
♪ The sands of time ♪
♪ There's a fight ♪
(cash register rings)
♪ But the battle to be won
is with the man inside ♪
♪ The man inside ♪
♪ No valley or ocean ♪
(sword scratching)
♪ (cash register rings) ♪
♪ Can stop my devotion ♪
♪ (horse whinnies) ♪
♪ (cash register rings) ♪
♪ Nothing will keep me
from getting to you ♪
♪ Flying high, to the limit ♪
♪ Never wondering how I touched the sky ♪
♪ Touched the sky ♪
♪ Like a dream ♪
(cash register ringing)
♪ You could never tell the lies ♪
♪ From what's exactly as it seems ♪
♪ In the rhythm, I believe ♪
(cash register ringing)
♪ Is the power of wings ♪
♪ There's a fire ♪
(cash register ringing)
♪ And it burns the deepest
fathoms of the seven seas ♪
♪ The seven seas ♪
♪ True desire ♪
(cash register ringing)
♪ Let the music in your heart ♪
♪ Give way to the things
that you believe ♪
(cash register ringing)
♪ Anything, you can achieve ♪
♪ Flying high, to the limit ♪
♪ Never wondering how
I kissed the clouds ♪
(cash register ringing)
♪ Like a dream ♪
♪ You can never tell the lies ♪
♪ From what's exactly as it seems ♪
♪ In the rhythm, I believe ♪
♪ Is the power of wings ♪
(cash register rings)
♪ Everything is achievable ♪
♪ Don't let nobody tear you down ♪
♪ Sexually ♪
♪ Just take flight, it's believable ♪
♪ If you first learn
to stand your ground ♪
(fireballs whooshing)
♪ Flying high, to the limit ♪
♪ Never wondering how I touched the sky ♪
♪ Like a dream ♪
♪ You can never the lies ♪
♪ From what's exactly as it seems ♪
♪ Within the rhythms, I believe ♪
♪ Is the power of wings ♪
(tongue squelches)
(upbeat vocal percussion music)
♪ Girl, I want you ♪
♪ But I know me ♪